to explore the origins of the fairy man
trapped inside the warren's room of
cursed artifacts we can look into the
case files that the paranormal couple
has documented on each of their
encounters with the supernatural this
one is titled the ferryman with the
words tehran's coins written below above
a case number this is the only direct
reference to the entity's true name
heron which comes from greek mythology
he represents the first example of greek
mythos in the conjuring franchise which
is known to explore middle eastern
american and even mexican central
american mythos geran is the son of
erebus deity of darkness and nyx goddess
of night according to worldhistory.org
the first known depiction of tehran
dates back to 500 bce on ancient greek
pottery so i will assume that he was
born sometime around then the name geran
has been translated by several sources
to fierce brightness which is certainly
interesting as the offspring of night
and darkness it may in fact be a
euphemism for death with here on
potentially being named after the bright
light that many people report seeing
before death or during a near-death
experience heroin is an example of a
psychopomp a deity responsible for
transporting the souls of the dead into
the afterlife his role was to charter
souls across a body of water depending
on which legend you're reading a river
or lake to drop them off in the
underworld realm of hades a damp gloomy
and lifeless domain where all mortals
are sent upon death referred to as the
realm of the dead it is said that very
few mortals could ever leave hades once
they entered it became tradition for
humans to place coins in the mouth of or
in some cases like the depiction scene
in annabelle comes home over the eyes of
the dead in order to pay the toll to
cross the river
[Music]
those who paid the fee would be loaded
into herron's ferry and taken across
into the realm of hades thus explaining
how he got his nickname the fairy man if
immortal did not pay the fee it is said
that their soul would be left to wander
the shores for 100 years before being
allowed to cross in some stories geron
would take and keep the soul while in
others they would haunt the world as
ghosts to learn the full history of the
fairy man including the details of his
story from ancient greek texts how
demonologist adam lorraine warren
captured this entity in the 1900s and
his resurgence in tandem with the demon
malthus in the 1970s stick around to the
end of this video this video is
sponsored by audible
welcome to another episode of horror
history today i continue my series on
the village of the controvers albeit
with much shorter hair because some of
those videos were filmed during the no
haircut era of the pandemic you couldn't
even call me shaggy in this it's way
longer than his the fairy man we are
talking about today is the conjuring
universe version seen in the 2019 film
annabelle comes home mixed with some of
the mythos that he's based on in that
movie herron has appeared many other
times in popular culture though from
being a boss fight in god of war chains
of olympus to being a silent rower in
disney's hercules and even getting his
own movie in the 2007 film of fairy man
to fully understand the fairy man's
journey let's take it back about 2 500
years into the stories of euripides
aeschylus and many other tragedians of
ancient greece
[Music]
as i mentioned the earliest heron
depiction was on a vase where he appears
as a bearded man carrying a punt pole
these poles would be used to move boats
in shallow water by the user planting
one end of the pool at the bottom of the
river and using it to propel forward the
most common channel cited as the river
that heron spends his time on would be
the river stags if only heron had
operated a sailboat as he does in some
later depictions it would have been the
perfect setup for some kind of joke the
coins left for the ferryman were known
as herron's obl based on the ancient
greek coin the oboe it equates to about
16 or 17 usd in 2022. different cultures
have adapted the story to fit their own
coin as we see an annabelle comes home
where daniela comes across a pouch of
coins of various types but don't try to
pay the ferryman using your debit card
or bitcoin wallet he has no use for
monetary value what he's interested in
is the silver the oboe was perfect for
him because the coins were worth their
weight in silver the oval was also used
as a measurement of weights although
most of the ancient greek tragedies
depicted the version of geron who
accepts payments as coins placed in the
corpse's mouth director gary doberman
was inspired by images of the coins
placed on the victim's eyes that he had
seen on the internet just as the mythos
evolved to include other coins the
description of geron has also changed
over the years in 438 bce in euripides
play alcestus herrera has evolved to use
an ore because the body of water being
crossed is now an enormous lake of
fathomless depth in 19 bce virgil's
aeneid describes him as appallingly
filthy with a bush of unkempt white
beard upon his chin with eyes like jets
of fire and a dirty cloak which draggles
down and nodded about his shoulders
around 100 ce seneca's hercules details
an old man clad in foul garb which is
described as an abhorrent sight his
beard is unkempt and his cheeks are
haggard and sunken in roman poetry of
the 2nd century paints an even grimmer
picture appulace's 1566 novel the golden
ass shame we didn't cover that one in
middle school language arts depicts an
old man with decaying hands and arms a
derivative version of the character can
also be found in etruscan mythology
where he is known as kharoon a demon of
death armed with a hammer there seems to
be a gradual transformation as we move
closer to present day towards a more
grim reaper-like appearance which was
consciously made a part of the design in
his controvers incarnation many of the
tales seem to be about heroes who cross
the river to retrieve someone or
complete a challenge in some mythos the
ferryman will help the hero and in
others he needs to be convinced in
hercules the titular hero was tasked to
retrieve the three-headed dog who
guarded the gates of hades and the fairy
man was punished severely for escorting
a living being into the realm of the
dead pinpointing when the warrens had
their encounter with the fairy men is a
little bit tricky they keep a file in
their office on the case and it contains
clues that we can use to further
determine the history of the mysterious
river captain of the underworld
i am about to dig into one of the many
case files of the demonologist ed and
lorraine warren this one is probably
movie only but they do have stories that
they've published meaning you can dig
into them yourself they explore
paranormal phenomena like haunted houses
graveyards and even a werewolf there is
only one place you can get these audio
books and that is autumn audible offers
an incredible selection of audiobooks
across every genre including lots of
horror you'll also discover exclusive
audible originals from top celebrities
renowned experts and exciting new voices
in audio members get a free title every
month for keeps plus there's a great
selection of free podcasts if you're new
here we have a little audio book club
here on the channel i tell you guys
about what i'm reading and you tell me
about what audible titles you've been
listening to in the comments this month
i'm veering off into non-fiction
territory with atomic habits by james
clear it explores the science behind
forming and keeping good habits that
lead to success and since my goal is to
sustain success with my channel i
figured it would be an excellent title
to check out to try out audible premium
plus for 30 days visit audible.com cz's
world or text cz's world to 500 500.
you'll find that link in the description
audible.com
the case file on the ferryman shows many
old photos but i think these are photos
that ed and lorraine collected not
necessarily snapshots that they took
themselves if you look at the clothes
that these people are wearing this guy
has a big old victorian bow tie and this
lady whose full portrait we see in the
behind the scenes content similarly has
a dress that matches what you might see
in victorian time the bodies are not yet
decomposed so these pictures were
probably taken well before ed and
lorraine were born another photo of a
candle in the grass next to some runes
and what looks like a witch totem is
labeled march 1921 again a good five
years before ed was even born it's also
not clear how this ties into the
ferryman so i think the most relevant
parts of this file are this hand drawn
map which is probably a map of the
catacombs that we see the ferryman
transform the warren's laundry room and
office closet into i don't necessarily
think these catacombs are supposed to
represent a location from the real world
i was not able to find an example of a
catacomb or crypt that has this mine
shaft look but if we want to use a real
location just for comparison's sake i
think the catacombs in milos greece
which were said to have been built
during the first century of the common
era makes sense according to the travel
website grika the catacombs are full of
labyrinths so that the romans could get
lost in them this was a way to protect
the bodies from their enemies this site
makes sense as a destination associated
with feron because people would want
their loved ones to be buried in a place
where grave robbers would not be able to
easily steal the fairy man's toll but i
think the image and most relevance to
the warren's investigation is hidden
behind the photo of the man with the
horseshoe mustache there's a photo of
two little girls with their eyes closed
i think these girls may be the younger
sisters of the girl who was taken by the
fairy man as explained by the character
danielle
it's this case the warren's investigated
about this girl who's terrorized by
something called the fairy man here's a
picture of the girl he killed one of
these girls could be the voice on the
audio tape in which ed warren interviews
a young girl about the disappearance of
her sister we hear this tape randomly
start playing as judy warren's
babysitter mary ellen is trying to
study points for his eyes she said his
life shows you the way to the land of
the
[Music]
[Applause]
another coin being dropped
it was like he was like he was calling
me have you ever seen the fairy man
he'll take your soul
it sounds as if the fairy man broke one
of his rules and came after a girl who
was still alive we don't really get
enough info to make a definitive
conclusion about why he does this but i
came prepared with a theory when i
explained the history of the ferryman's
various depictions and culture across
time we saw the deity becoming more and
more grim reaper-like with the annabelle
comes home version sporting a nose
indent like you would see on a skull and
wearing something similar to the
reaper's cloak if we look at versions of
a grim reaper in other cultures a common
theme is that interfering with death's
design can result in death the big one
that comes to mind is final destination
where certain characters have
clairvoyant visions allowing them to
escape their death but death continues
to come for them in other ways until
they succumb i actually did a horror
history episode on death in final
destination if you're interested in
japanese culture gods of death are known
as shinigami and there's a fantastic
series about them known as death note in
death note if one shinigami tries to
extend the life of a human whose
lifespan is expired that shinigami will
die this is the only known way to kill a
shinigami perhaps one of the sisters
somehow saved the life of the older
sister who was supposed to die and is
now being punished there's nothing in
the movie to back this theory up but it
seems like this may have been the
original idea based on the content of
this deleted scene in it mary ellen
explains that when she was 5 years old
she got really sick and almost died
i came so close to dying
i didn't feel anything and she is
actually the only character in the movie
that the fairy man goes after i think
he's targeted her because she was
supposed to die when she was five years
old but perhaps because the warrants had
already captured the fairy man inside
this coin pouch he was not able to take
her from the land of the living until he
was released it all started in 1968 the
warrens had just investigated the case
of a supposedly possessed doll named
annabelle and they decided to take the
doll and keep it in their cursed
artifact room for safe keeping on the
way home their car broke down outside of
a cemetery and they discovered that
other spirits were drawn to malthus the
demon bound to this doll it's the doll
ed
it's a beacon for other spirits the doll
sat in this case until 1972 when the
warrens were away for an evening and
mary ellen was babysitting for judy her
friend daniella came over and snuck into
the locked room hoping to find a way to
contact her father on the other side in
doing so she touches everything
including the coin pouch that the fairy
man was bound in malthus tricks daniella
into opening the annabelle case and she
leaves without properly locking it so
the demon simply leans the doll forward
against the glass in order to escape
because the demon is a beacon for other
spirits every spirit locked in that room
is drawn to malthus who presumably
provides them with the power to get out
of the room and terrorize the house the
ferryman lures mary ellen into the
warren's office using the sound of the
interview tape from their investigation
on him she hears a coin a drop as one of
the coin-eyed spirits seen in the
photograph appears in the room behind
her she goes back to the hall where
another coin rolls down the stairs and
lands at her feet she picks it up and
examines it to find several slashes
across the surface as if something very
powerful had scratched at it repeatedly
hard enough to do physical damage the
fairy man continues to roll his precious
coins in her direction sending her on a
path to the source when she reaches the
kitchen an almost insectile hissing
sound directs her attention to the
laundry room
that's when she first lays eyes on
what's at this point has only been a
figure of greek legend to her she locks
eyes with two coins floating near the
ceiling in the dark
[Music]
the positioning of the fairy man
seemingly perched on the ceiling is
something that we've seen before in the
annabelle spin-off movies on multiple
occasions malthus has climbed around on
a ceiling before pouncing down on his
prey for this reason i would assume the
fairy man is seemingly performing the
same ceiling hang trick here is a result
of influence by malthus whether malthus
simply taught him how to do it or took
hold of him in the same fashion we saw
the demon valik take hold of the old man
of bill wilkins in the conjuring 2. in
any event mary ellen is able to defend
herself by shining her flashlight at the
coins causing the fairy man to disappear
and the coins to fall to the ground her
flashlight dies and she picks up one of
the coins to examine it but as she does
so the fairy man rushes forward right in
front of her coins once again cover his
eyes and we get a good look at his dark
dry looking face mary ellen screams and
tries to run for it but she's knocked to
the ground by a supernatural force then
irrigated back into the darkness she's
only able to stop herself by grabbing
onto a door frame for dear life at this
point the fairy man's powers seem to be
the standard set of abilities seen on
most paranormal entities in the
controvers ability to move around
quickly climb on walls and ceilings
interact with technology become
invisible and of course eat people and
objects seemingly out of thin air while
invisible but his next move is not
something we've really seen from the
other creatures deborah's laundry room
is instantly transformed into the
catacombs and spirits with token eyes
appear in coffins on each side of him as
he raises a warm dim lantern up around
his face like the illusion daniella
experiences where she appears to be
stabbed by a knife this room
transformation is only visual and the
house would return to normal after mary
ellen's flashlight comes back to life
and she shines it in phaeron's direction
the fairy man retreats into the closet
in ed and lorraine's office but not
before retrieving the annabelle doll
which the girls would need to return to
its case to have any hope of stopping
the horrors wreaking havoc around the
house
annabelle
the doll she's the one who's doing all
of this when they arrive the fairy man
creaks open the closet door to give them
a peek and reveal annabelle then slam it
shots before they can get to it they're
able to locate the key but when mary
ellen reopens the door the closet has
transformed into the catacombs of the
fairy man at the end of the corridor
mary ellen sees the girl that the fairy
man killed the one that looks just like
her eyes covered and holding the
annabelle dawn it was a trap to coax her
further into the crypt but she had no
choice but to venture forward to
retrieve the doll her lamp goes out this
is the second time mary ellen's source
of light was extinguished in the
ferryman's presence and it makes me
wonder if the infernal deity named for
intense light as the sun of night and
darkness has the ability to manipulate
light sources she is unable at first to
pry the doll from her doppelganger's
grasp the girl comes to life and screams
although we don't know exactly how mary
ellen got a hold of the doll she is able
to grab it and throw it forward to judy
and she's only able to scream for her to
go after judy and mary ellen try to
return the doll malthus uses its power
to prevent them from closing the
encasing and the fairy man along with
the other spirits released into the
house close in on them but with
daniela's help they're able to close the
door and the fairy man and all of the
other threats that malthus released that
evening were contained once more
the evil has been contained could we see
the fairy man return in another
controversy movie i mean maybe he's
technically like he's still there if
malthus gets out again anything could
happen but no let's be real it's not
gonna happen to fully understand the
lore behind malthus and the rest of the
evil deities in the controversy you need
to click on that playlist on the left
but first remember to subscribe to cz's
world for new horrors every week ring
the death bell and select all
notifications and i will see you in the
next video assuming we both survive
[Music]